and as we've been reporting the
situation in southern Gaza is becoming
even more dire as eight trucks have been
stopped at the rougher Crossing and
shellings resumed let's bring in James
Elder he is unicef's global spokesperson
and he's joining us live from Gaza Mr
Elder thank you very much for your time
what impact has the ceasefire ending had
on people there that you can
see yeah hi it's hard to hear your
questions if we talk about Aid um the
aid in the last seven days across the
United Nations has been so critical I
mean this is life-saving Aid and we know
it's what people are asking for food and
water and medicine that's what's being
delivered but it cannot stop we know
it's not enough because of the the
restrictions the immense restrictions
and the the attacks over weeks and weeks
but it's the right type of aid but yes
today it came to a grinding halt the
only thing we really saw today was more
casualties and fear returning to
Children Mr Elder let me try to speak up
and perhaps speak a little bit more
slowly because of the trouble that
you're having hearing with the aid
stopping what impact are you seeing that
having on people already who for seven
eight weeks now have not had enough of
the bare necessities to get
by we've said for weeks that the great
great fear that the United Nations has
here that the the we might see that the
attack on children not just from the sky
and was pausing for a week thank
goodness but it we we'll see it on the
ground that we will see a devastating
increase in the deps particularly of
children the most vulnerable here in
Gaza because of disease because of all
the things your correspondent said A
desperate lack of water barely 10% of
water systems are functioning here to
their capacity because people will tell
you in the streets they need food and we
bring in trucks and trucks but it needs
hundreds of trucks and of course
medicine same thing hospitals that
should be referral hospitals like aliab
in in the north is now a war zone so
people are desperate and and and that
desperation will only be increasing it's
not just desperation it's a sadness you
see from children who look and say I'm
hungry or I want to go to my home or I
don't want to I'm 13 years old I'm a
girl I don't want to queue for three
hours to a toilet these are the things
we were seeking to address and this
nightmare for people today just somehow
got so much worse and are you having
conversations with Israel with Hamas
with countries like the United States
who have a lot of influence with Israel
to get them to resume the
ceasefire again I'm sorry but yes I
think what you're asking on the
ceasefire is we have pleaded UNICEF the
United Nations all the way to the
Secretary General the only Humane thing
the only the only plausible thing if we
are not again as a world going to say
never again and then reflect upon again
just occurred a humanitarian ceasefire
that gives the United Nations a chance
to get the aid unra this biggest agency
Desperately Seeking to reach people
remembering so many of my colleagues in
the United Nations here they've lost
family members they too are displaced
and they're doing everything they can
but now again under bombardment so yes
we appeal in every Corridor of power we
can use every influence we possibly got
to to get a ceasefire it is the only
Humane thing because as you rightly say
the criticality of food water medicine
but at the same time hospitals are
absolutely overall the health staff
heroic health staff who run from Patient
to Patient but I see the hospitals I see
the children with wounds of War on the
ground today I saw you know in hospitals
children I've been seeing it all week
and playing with I'd started to see
childhood returning that little Glimpse
in children that you know a bit of
normality and then when I went back
today again fear had taken over so we
hope that those few leaders around the
world who seem to be able to have
influence can capture that fear capture
that childhood capture that immense
potential that I see in every young guys
that I speak to and can understand that
that is what we are seeking to protect
here Mr Elder you have a unique ability
to convey the situation the experience
of people in Gaza what is it that you're
telling the leaders who have the power
to change this situation and are they
listening are you
hopeful I'm telling them to to look into
the eyes of shimer the little 8-year-old
girl I've seen the last four days who
has barely spoken to her aunt and is
just starting to speak again why hasn't
Shima spoken because she's traumatized
because she's had her right arm and her
right leg blown off she's getting
medical care now but she's eight she
knows her world has changed
forever I want them to look in her eyes
and to understand that there's a
thousand children we think in Gaza who
have had some form of amputation we
cannot in all good conscience possibly
see that that repeated that continued
again Shima today by the way is no
longer talking that Fe
has returned for Hope for hope I I turn
to the people I speak to the people who
know the the Palestinians and they will
say to me James I've lost my wife my
daughter my job my ability to feed my
remaining children all I've got left
left is hope that the world anyone with
influence anyone with a voice owes it to
that man owes it to shimer to protect
that hope and Mr Elder more than 6,000
Palestinian children have been killed in
Gaza since October the 7th more than 100
un workers and with every un worker
that's killed it's one less person that
can help the people in Gaza so what is
your message to Israel to the Waring
parties here again to stop the
Bloodshed well exactly stop stop the
Bloodshed protect those workers who are
on the front lines who themselves have
families who are trying as best they can
to support as many people and that need
just keeps growing protect them protect
journalists protect children it it
sounds very simple of course it's not
but what the longer this goes on the
more the polarization the anger the
frustration the further we get away from
this so I guess a message from UNICEF is
that people have to be able to hold
multiple contradictory thoughts at the
same time about who's inflicted Horrors
upon who but at the at the same time
that they are children that they are
women that you know that the 21y old
fourth year medical student I met who I
think is one of those girl young ladies
who from the age of 10 has probably been
studying five hours a day beautiful mind
big heart she just bought her her
stethoscope and her gown it was her
first time now to be able to do
practical work the glow in this young
lady's eyes but just reduced to tears
she said to me James I don't want to go
to hospitals as a doctor bury people
everywhere I go I see the potential the
young guy who caught me on the street up
in up in the Gaza City who has learned
to speak English great English has
learned to become an electrical engineer
on the internet the potential in this
place is incredible I want those leaders
to understand this is what they want
from their countries this is all the
people of Gaza all the moms and dads
it's all they want for their children
that potential to come to the four let
those dreams live let let the children
live that is unicef's global
spokesperson James Elder joining us live
from Gaza we thank you very much for
bringing us those stories from the Gaza
Strip we really appreciate
it thank you